this morning on the dish chef Peter
Serpico born in South Korea he was
adopted at age 2 by an American couple
and grew up in suburban Maryland after
culinary school he had the good fortune
to meet his mentor New York star chef
David Chang winning a James Beard Award
as head chef at Chang's acclaimed
Momofuku Coe in 2013 he stepped out on
his own leaving New York for
Philadelphia and opening his namesake
Serpico in one instant acclaim as one of
the city's best with a modern American
menu in a comfortable neighborhood
setting and chef Peter Serpico good
morning welcome to the dish about this
spread which is magnificent so this is
basically from my childhood all through
my career we have starting we have a
crab boil
we've Korean fried chicken wings this is
my mom's mac and cheese that I grew up
on Korean short ribs with kimchi and
apple cake the finish in terms of your
grandmother's influence on you as a chef
I read somewhere that you said you could
eat more lasagna than Garfield Garfield
is a personal hero of mine and a noted
the lasagna consumer
tell us about those experiences growing
up on Italian I had I had two
grandmother's that I both really really
enjoyed food they were both amazing
cooks my while my mom's mom her go-to
was the apple pie and we would always
have it she would have it waiting for us
when we arrived in Chicago after a
14-hour Drive and then the my other
grandmother her go two's were like
lasagna and sausage and peppers things
like that just both amazing cooks was it
jump going from that to Momofuku which
is very Asian influenced Korean driven
delightful fare different absolutely
well one was a profession so I cooked I
cooked a moment fuku professionally so
it's a little bit different you started
in New York sort of through a series of
internships correct yes what took you to
New York I just I grew up in Maryland I
was at a point where one of my mentors
set me up to
move to New York de stodg for free so I
checked out some kitchens there and two
weeks later I moved and some of the
kitchens that you've dodged and are some
of the greatest in New York history I
mean we're talking about lespinasse
we're talking about Bulli what was that
experience like oh it was amazing it was
a I was 19 years old and I never even I
didn't know that food could taste that
good I've never been in like a
professional kitchen there was just so
many moving parts just being around so
many people just seeing like the
well-oiled machine and I I was I was
working in a kitchen before that with uh
it was a chef in myself when you get to
New York you at some point you have to
make the decision you're gonna go off on
your own which is a scary decision yes
yes how did you make that leap I I don't
know it just happened I felt like I was
a little bit burnt out I wanted to leave
I wanted to start a family man I I was
in New York for 11 years and I felt like
it was time for a change
so when you landed in cahoots with the
great Stephen Starr not bad it's not bad
Philadelphia
chef as I asked you to sign this dish I
will ask you the question of all
questions which is if you could share
this bounty and it really is a bounty
with any figure past or present what
would it be I would say Barry Sanders
he's the greatest running back of all
time underdog and I really appreciate
that and I appreciate his humility more
than anything and he'd probably be able
to consume Peter Serpico Thanks and for
more on Chef Serpico and the dish head
to our website at CBS this morning
dot-com